[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts once again the Lord has blessed
us and Bert is sick bird is under
dialysis and we're hoping he recovers
soon it's official Bert is HIV positive
Bert is undergoing a double kidney
transplant Burt underwent a full body
blood transfusion and word from the
doctor is it's going well your dream
continues bird is not here
it is so much better to do this podcast
without the regular co-host
your dream finally came true Bert has
passed away his replacement is so much
more fun sitting in for him
is the Great
Duncan Trussell Ron White here with us
Ryan thanks for coming thanks for having
me back thanks for coming Duncan all
right thank you for having me it's great
to have you Greg Simmons how you doing
buddy Gianna's Papa's everybody let him
hear it let him hear it thanks for
sitting in Joe my pleasure
hey guys new episode of two bears one
cave and we've got Whitney Cummings
today is Monday October 24th and the two
bears one cave barrel of the Bears
competition officially crowned a winner
this weekend on Instagram with comedy
fans getting to vote on their favorite
two bears one cave guest of all time and
a 16-man single elimination tournament
welcome back to the joke World comedy
update every single Monday bringing you
all the common news that you need to
know from your favorite comedians your
favorite podcast literally anything and
everything to do with comedy all in one
place all in one YouTube channel so
please consider subscribing to joke
world right now if you haven't yet
follow us on Instagram turn on the post
notifications and download this episode
on Spotify if you really want to support
the show
if you don't want to support the show do
not download this on Spotify I swear to
God if you're Michael Jordan Tiger Woods
you're not like oh I'm competitive it's
a completely other level he looks like
an AI dream now I know when you see him
without his hat it's like an AI was like
what is old Tiger Woods look like it's
it's he you know I think that was all
tied together uh chasing that tail and I
think Jordan was probably like that that
we don't he was before social media yeah
but I think those I think he had to be
out there it's Michael can you imagine
like why can't why can't my wife
understand that listen honey I'm at the
top of my field I'm like the Michael
Jordan of guys shirtless doing comedy
yeah I I gotta slay [ __ ] I got a sleigh
[ __ ] I would love I've never slayed
[ __ ] she probably would understand just
do it and tell her about it yeah so out
of the 16 total guests that were
involved in this tournament the bracket
was divided eight and eight the top
eight guests that were on episodes with
just Bert and then the top eight guests
that were on episodes just with Tom now
on each side of the bracket one person
would emerge after the voting and they'd
face off in the championship to
determine who was the top bear who was
the best bear ever I guess the third
bear in the one cave
to start off on bird side of the bracket
you had Whitney Cummings Stevo Ari
shaffir Christina P Andrew Santino Sal
vulcano Chris estefano and Mark Norman
then Tom side the bracket was Leanne
Giannis Papas Tim Dillon Ethan Klein
Felipe Anthony Jeselnik Bobby Lee and
Joe Rogan so Tom has some of the more
Heavy Hitters on his side like Tim
Dillon Joe Rogan and then Bert has some
more value spread in between it I
remember one time I was working clubs in
like 2012. I'd known Julia a few years
and he just called me one said he goes
what are you doing I'm like ah I'm in
Kansas City and uh you know he's like
what are you doing in Kansas City I go I
have a show tonight he goes you know
what kind of [ __ ] Momo goes out on a
Sunday
I was like what he's like you can't do
that you can't do Sunday shows I go but
I I ha it's part of my contract because
you tell them you tell them I don't do
Sunday shows I'm not a [ __ ] loser
piece of [ __ ] and I was like okay I'll
tell them I love Sunday shows yeah I'm
like all right so this shows are casual
I know people are relaxed you could have
a more relaxed kind of like Thursdays
and Sundays I love them so fun I love I
love Mondays and Tuesdays too I love all
the days of the week [ __ ] it's a
great job Tommy bun again this was voted
on by the fans on Bird's Instagram story
so it's no surprise that Rogan was able
to make it to the finals pretty easily
just based on numbers alone he has the
biggest audience he has the biggest
podcast so of course he's gonna have
more fans voting for him to make it to
the finals that was no surprise Mark
Norman was the comedian to make it out
of burnt side of the bracket which gave
you the championship matchup set up to
be Joe Rogan versus Mark Norman Battle
of the Bears surprisingly because of
Rogan's audience size this was 50 50 in
the vote for a long time it was neck and
neck bad it out as close as it could be
literally 50 50 between Norman and Rogan
with the winner eventually pulling it
out in an upset Mark Norman wins the
battle of the Bears competition being
crowned the funniest best most exciting
electric two bears one cave guest of all
time queefing his way to victory in this
one I love that they did this on
Instagram it was very interactive for us
fans I like that we were able to get
involved with the show see who we
thought was our funniest our favorite
guests but what do you think do you
think that Mark Norman is the best two
bears one cave guests of all time do you
think it's someone else someone that
might not have even been listed in the
original tournament that didn't even
make the bracket who do you think is the
best two bears on Cave guests of all
time I want you to leave it in the
comments we're gonna do our own vote
based on just this comment section and
we'll put up a winner the joke world two
bears one cave Barrel the Bears second
Champion it also might be Mark Norman
still he kills it on that show every
time so no surprise here congrats to
Mark have you ever gotten the message
um hey man I love your comedy I've got a
couple jokes if you want to hear them
like that all the time yeah and you're
like yeah yeah I want to hear your joke
with three n-words in it for no reason
yeah I'll take it what do you Mark
Norman
comedy Andrew Schultz announced in his
recent episode of flagrant that he'll be
acting alongside Snoop in a movie set to
come out about peewee football I'm doing
this [ __ ] movie with Snoop and
basically you know Snoop is a big peewee
football guy he always been coaching for
[ __ ] years so he made essentially
he's making like Bad News Bears but with
pee wee football yeah so he's the coach
of like the underdog team the movie's
called underdogs and I'm the coach of
the like the bougie team I'm like the
villain yeah
although this isn't technically Andrew's
movie it's gonna be dope to see him on
the big screen working alongside these
big names and acting and this plus Tim
Dylan saying he wants to make a movie
Birds movie about Russia coming out
whenever that war is over or whatever uh
Bobby and Theo working to produce
something together it just the future
looks bright for comedians being able to
do their own [ __ ] and Branch out into as
many Avenues as they want which is sweet
we're gonna make a movie guys I just
want to let you guys know that I've been
telling you guys this way like there are
things that I've noticed about
filmmaking that uh I want to learn more
about it and I want to learn more about
like story and all these things I'm not
going to disrespect the craft but um
we can we can absolutely do it Are You
Gonna Act in the movie yeah oh yeah I
want to act on it I guess it'll be it'll
be it'll be absolutely yeah okay it'll
be absolutely incredible yeah because of
that
no I wanna uh yeah yeah I would like to
act it absolutely but uh most
importantly want to be involved in like
the creation of the story
or can we play someone else no no one
plays themselves can I play Alex yeah
yeah this is the best movie ever Yeah by
you yes absolutely yeah you can play
Mark done no but it can't be about us
they have the same age you have to have
a great
lifelinehead's first ever live show last
week the podcast hosted by Chris and
matalia went live Wednesday October 19th
which is also matthalia's birthday happy
birthday Matt Dalia but they answered
phone calls took messages from fans on
Discord and even had some surprise
people pop in like Eric Griffin and
special guests and sign merch and
surprise other things yes
and Booyah yup there we go if you'd like
to watch the replay of their life event
tickets are still available for just
five dollars at watchlifeline.com Guest
spots from last week your mom's house
talk with Stevo two bears one cave was
Burton Tom Tom and Bert whiskey Ginger
had on nimish Patel flagrant did not
have a guest they did the roast of Kanye
West which did not go very well if you
read the comments but I'll let you make
your own judgments there and Bobby Lee
was on are you garbage I don't know why
he said this but he said pull out 20
grand
cash yeah really yeah so I did means
you're buying all right yes I'm gonna
buy it how many years in the Mad TV is
this
two years maybe two years you got 20 G's
but not but no because at the second
year you negotiated the show is probably
doing well so yeah and then also I had
booked other things you know like I had
done Harold and Kumar I'd done other
things in between there so a little bit
of cash that's a little cash so I go I
pulled out 20 grand what did you carry
the 20 grand to the brown paper bag
brown paper bag I remember that I like
how you got mad at the question to
realize how relevant it was a relevant
one yeah yeah I mean you know what let's
start over this past weekend with Theo
Von was a solo episode no guest the
Honeydew talked with Eddie Bravo Joe
Rogan had on Robert Kelly we might be
drunk also had on Stevo and Giannis
Pappas was the guest on the Tim Dylan
show new comedy specials out right now I
got three of them for you checked out
the first one is Gabriel Iglesias
Stadium fluffy on Netflix with the
description reading offending a
professional boxer trick-or-treating
with his son Gabriel shares his highs
and lows in this Landmark stand-up
special that was filmed at Dodger
Stadium which is pretty sweet so you can
go check that one out and Netflix right
now also on Netflix is Eliza Schlesinger
hot forever and Robert Kelly killbox is
available on Louis ck.com for just ten
dollars I hear really good things about
that one as well that's something to
check out that's it for specials and
that's it for this week's joke World
comedy update thank you again so much
for watching this comedy news we'll be
back next Monday with some more common
news but in the meantime we're gonna be
posting other videos on this channel
compilation edits fan reaction videos
anything you could ask for all comedy
literally this channel is just if you
love comedy follow this channel it'll be
worth it I promise and also follow us on
Instagram download this episode on
Spotify we have a second Channel clip
world that's all our [ __ ] there it is
for you thank you for supporting the
brand for supporting the channel
um sweet that's it enjoy the outro maybe
click on one of these videos keep
watching joke World content
whatever man whatever whatever you want
to do now that's up to you so yeah thank
you I'm gonna stop rambling and we'll
see you next Monday
[Music]